it's been a it's been a long time since
1962 but now we're seeing people in Cuba
start to protest sitting down with
dictatorship yeah are you getting that
spark back to if you're do you feel
hopeful he never lost that spark I mean
since he left I think there hasn't been
a day that's passed that he hasn't
thought about uh you know the cause of
bringing Freedom back to Cuba and he he
ever every single day that I can
remember every single chance that he's
had he is uh dedicated his life here to
that fight for freedom in Cuba whether
it's through his uh Cuban Civic
committee where they put on
um events throughout money yeah but I
mean there's tons of stuff that he's
been doing today so to answer your
question there was no spark that needed
to come back it was the fire has always
been burning since the day he left
and well there's more hope now if I if I
understand your question is well what is
my reaction well
is is a reaction of of
sadness
that people
had no other chance of surviving than
living day by day
and could not really free themselves
because they in my case okay I have no
problem in being in the underground it
was for me
great
I didn't have anything didn't have no
security didn't have I wasn't afraid of
anything didn't even know that I was in
danger
but I never had
a song
that would go to bed without milk
I I never had a mother that was dying
with no medical services
I was a young healthy Cuban
doing whatever he needed he learned in a
school
as I said I I I had the pleasure of
having had
a better education than my than the
economic situation of my parents could
afford but we didn't have a car
we live in a middle class neighborhood
low lower middle class not bad in El
Cerro was okay
and I I had a good standard of living
but people today had not been able to do
what I did
because they had responsibility with
their families I didn't have there are
many young people that don't have
families but they needed to survive on a
day-to-day day-to-day day to day they
never took for me was for for me was not
a process of not being able to eat
or to find food to fight
I fought and then I had no food and I
didn't give
her I don't want to say anything
okay never never felt hungry
I I own the contrary
I always felt okay and then my friends
will come
and one will say one day oh what shoe
size you were
because he saw Halls on my on my shoes
Maya
[Music]
one of the guys that was with me the day
that I jump out of a car when they take
it they were taking me to prison
and Alejandro Maya Luca might choose and
say what side do you charge you you were
okay so next week I am in the parking
Central delawanna waiting for him again
and he comes to laughing with a box of
shoes no shoes for me
and you know I didn't I didn't even know
I didn't have but I didn't even care
about the truth that I have but today
and the Revolution have been able to
control the human people
by a scarcity
by hunger by a starvation but there is a
point a Breaking Point
for people to
I would like to talk I don't want to
forget write it there I want to talk
about this who
the qm program in Hanoi during the
Vietnam war oh yeah okay but now the
people have suffered so much
I think they are in a catatonic estate
they don't give
nothing about what happens now they are
willing to risk it now they have nothing
to lose
now Castro is dead and his brother Raul
yeah is he dead no he's alive is he in
control
president
is now the like acting president and
face of the regime in Cuba no
is he willing to give it up no no no no
no no no no no actually he's broken up
he said bureaucrat he has power he did
nothing for the revolution he didn't
fight but it he did nothing he just was
you know a good he absorbed the theory
of Marxism
he lives in a huge mansion with swimming
pool
do you think he's gonna give up that his
his actual you know he he was addressing
um I saw a video he's addressing people
about the protests and his exact words
were uh you know if they want to face
off
with the revolution they're going to
have to walk over our dead bodies so you
know his answer is he and he gave an
order for combat in the streets we're
going to go to the streets and we're
going to he said he he called on the
Revolutionary citizens to fight back yep
it's amazing how they refer to
themselves as the revolution when
they've been the dictators for decades
yeah Generations
they are
traders to the Revolution and by the way
when we use the World Revolution
really we it was not a revolution social
with social or nothing on it was a
movement
to get rid of a detailer
that we have for seven years and go back
to what we were not jumping with ideas
and plans and things that never happened
or that would never never achieve their
things like the stories of the chickens
in the farm Fidel said oh we got started
with this Farm we're gonna have so many
chickens and never and then and we're
gonna have a hundred million chickens
here soon
and there were no chickens and nothing
appeared and nothing happened do you
understand those yeah the the command
the command economies don't work I mean
we saw it with uh with MAO when he said
kill all the birds kill all the pests
and then they destroyed their their
their ability to farm yeah all of a
sudden the locusts came and started
sweeping across uh China no no farmers
in Cuba now are starving they are not
allowed to sell what they what they can
produce they don't know how to produce
everything has to be controlled by the
government everything has to go to land
this is why I say please Americans open
your eyes
need food doesn't need humanitarian aid
q1 needs to get rid of the dictatorship
that will absorb anything you send over
there nobody in the streets is saying I
want food I want a vaccine against Kobe
no
they want freedom they know it's the
only thing
but what can America do well Americans
should get involved in that I think that
the American government should help us
at this time
do you know what happened in in 1961
with division of hero
okay there were you know in Miami
as as young Killers began to go from
Havana from Cuba to Miami in Miami when
they knew they were going to prepare a
force to fight they are attracted to
volunteer
also known as a Bay of Pigs that's right
oh yes right right right okay they they
started to volunteer and they wanted to
to to go to Cuba to live at a Cuba but
then Kennedy changed the plans
and Kennedy was told but listen
what do we do with the 1500 humans
that want to go
and then his advice of the world Mr
President they want to go to Cuba they
want to go to fight and then he said
okay send them
but no air coverage
no support
that was like sending like sending
the best of the q1 youth in Exile to die
this country has to
pay us back
because after that
you know what had happened in 62 years
week you must expect the United States
to behave like the United States maybe
in the 50s I don't know I don't know
when to go back
okay but I do know that the United
States had a Prestige and international
British
that we Cubans were
in love with the American dream that we
were living in our own country and that
we relief when hours ended and we came
here
looking to establish you know a new life
I came looking for something different
to tell you the truth in Miami this past
election there was a safe Democrat
District in a an urban center
no one saw this coming the Republican
got elected the continuing pushes from
the far left the the marxists the black
lives matter groups is turning many of
these you know in like South Texas for
instance and in Florida it's turning
Democrat areas into Republican areas and
it's and very likely because especially
in Miami obviously the people who know
the horrors of socialism and communism
are seeing that within the United States
and pushing back against it so perhaps
that's that's that's a sign of hope for
us here that we won't let it happen
and I wonder if the if people in the
United States are willing to do anything
to help Cuba thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time